hey guys and welcome back to steampunks
my name is Jasmin Tom and I'm admin Tran
and we did tell you last week that we
were gonna spend today's episode of
games what's PC focus sure talking about
the most disappointing games of 2018 but
we did decide we probably don't need
another Avenue to tell you the full yeah
I don't want to start it is what it is
let's move on and I don't think I played
that many other games this year that
really disappointed me there are few
smaller ones here but like nothing that
I really need to like get my you know
event that's right don't you feel like
that so let's not do that
that can't be negative let's be positive
but what we did get is talking about was
games that were excited about that are
coming out next yeah especially in
particular those coming to PC so let's
get going on talking about some of those
I'm gonna start off with a way smaller
game that people probably haven't heard
of called dragon I hope I'm pronouncing
that right it's Norwegian so dragon is
the next game from red thread games who
were responsible for their longest
journey and dream for games and it's a
first-person adventure set in 1920s
Norway she plays this American Edward
who's ventured off to Norway with his
ward Lisi younger woman and he's
basically looking for a sister who's
gone missing it sounds like it's being
set up to be a bit like the vanishing of
Ethan Carter or what remains of Edith
Finch it's that kind of sort of pseudo
horror mystery but leaning more on the
mystery side so I feel like this gotta
be a dragon dragon the dragon right well
I mean another part of this is it's
psychological so it plays on both
psychological mystery element so it's an
imaginary dress might be actually it
might be and it's also brings out the
theme of the unreliable narrator which
is one of my favorite things that games
play with the narrative so I think that
could be really cool cool you've brought
your ward with you so you're actually
going to be chatting with someone the
whole time which is a bit of a different
take on the first-person adventure and
red thread have just proved to be so
good at storytelling I'm really looking
forward to seeing what they
with this the studio itself is 12 people
there based in Norway themselves
it looks really gorgeous there's only a
teaser trailer out now so the game is
slated for 2019
oh they're given how long it took train
full chapters to come out fingers
crossed that that will actually be the
day but yeah it looks really cool and
I'm excited for when it does come okay I
wasn't gonna do this one first but now
it kind of like seems like a natural
segue so one of the games I'm looking
forward to in 2019 is in the valley of
gods which is being developed by campus
Santa who are the guys who did fire
watch and it recently got acquired by a
valve so good for them I'm really
looking forward to this because you
mentioned that in drag and you have a
war that someone you're talking to yeah
and in value of gods you are roaming
around and exploring a Egyptian ruin in
the 1920s as well as well yeah in fire
watch you know you obviously had a
connection with a voice on our radio and
this is the first time they are
introducing a character model you know
that team is really great at telling
stories like they are obviously two of
the co-founders were the directors of
the original season of The Walking Dead
which was also a game where you kind of
had a narrator or a protagonist who had
done stuff that you weren't really sure
yeah oh you know and you kind of had to
work that out and kind of like adjust
your sort of interactions to sort of
cater for that I guess that's the kind
of the same here and they've got on the
same with fire watch to imply watch you
know Henry you wasn't weren't really
sure about what his past life was yeah
and in this one you and your partners
are I believe her name is going together
on like one last big adventure but
apparently you have beef between you and
you know that whole dynamic of sort of
strain relationship is really
interesting and I'm really keen to see
how they pull off this story and sort of
see how they change things up because I
don't think this team is one to just
rehash stuff that they've done before
and so I'm looking forward to seeing
what like sort of the filmmaking
mechanic that we've kind of seen a bit
of has to do with the adventure and yeah
just generally how they go about telling
this
story with all these sort of new things
that they haven't they didn't use in
Firewatch sometime 2019 not sure whether
that has a proper date yet but maybe it
could be 2020 but anyway I'm looking
forward to it regardless if it does come
in to you 19
[Music]
so now for something completely
different in a game that is not set in
the 1929 sense no adventure on guns well
yeah if you want guns yeah the other
game I picked is something completely
different Division two
I really loved the first one which I did
makes me a Swede cuz all I do on this
show is complaining about how much I
hate playing games to other people and I
find the games like this tedious but I
absolutely loved the world the division
blonde built I liked all the
collectibles and I really enjoyed how
easy it was to matchmake into braids and
matchmaking to missions when I didn't
have friends online to play with I just
had a really good time with it and I'm
so excited for the second one I like
that it's following this trend we're
seeing of a bunch of games where that
are moving away from the desolate
concrete jungle into trying to do
something a little tiny now make it a
little more interesting I think
Washington DC looks like a really cool
setting mm-hmm
you know I'm sort of expecting more of
the same but I do appreciate that I
think Ubisoft really became aware of the
mistakes they may be the first game
particularly with the endgame content
yeah cuz I mean I always playing with
you at the time the main reason I
stopped playing that game is that the
first huge thing they brought out once
you finished the game was just say well
I guess it was just a wave mode yeah
just a set of waves and after all of the
like compelling story content up to that
point like the little side things you
could do stuff that actually felt
engaging it was such a shame to just be
thrown into a warehouse and just have
endless dudes throwing I really wonder
if I would have kept going with that
game if I didn't hit a massive road one
dlc one yeah and the main shame is
apparently that game vastly improving
the updates that come up I came after
that yeah but I didn't happen to step
back in so I'm excited for this new
opportunity to get into the division
world again but you think it's so much
fun I love co-op campaigns like whenever
there's a chance to do a co-op campaign
even if it is like shooting bullets
punch enemies I just had a load of fun
with this game and it's coming and March
so we actually know this one's coming
and there's going to be a beta before
then so that'll be really fun yeah I'm
looking forward to this one to agents of
division are the only ones standing
against it
but how do you save a nation when its
enemies come from within
[Music]
now obviously the division is a
multi-platform title and there are heaps
of multi-platform games I'm we're
looking forward to next year that's like
don't make Cry 5 Resident Evil remake to
Ace Combat you've got your Psychonauts
to which I'm really keen enforce that I
thought I'd make my second pick a PC PC
game pcs PC PC game it's exclusively a
game for now and this one is called
Phoenix point which if you're not
familiar with it it is a tactical
strategy game
very much in the vein of XCOM that it's
being designed by the guy who originally
created XCOM Julian Gollop
so this is kind of his return to the
return to the genre he created as he
puts it in his trailers and stuff the
whole just that this thing has the
slight Palace x1 so the game takes place
on earth and there's an invading alien
force the aliens coming from the sea is
coming from within it's one of those
games where aliens have really taken
over the earth and it's have fractured
humanity and it's up to you know you as
a faction leader to sort of fight back
the opposing forces as well as negotiate
with the other human factions so there's
a big focus on the tactical strategy
which looks a lot like the exome reboot
that fracas did which is not a bad thing
it's like a really great gold standard
to sort of compare yourself to and
that's a whole lot into the world
tragedy layer which involves sort of
moving your bases around like
negotiating with other factions like
knowing what where your front lines are
and like how to push back and sort of
knowing which places to go to like
making those compromises of like Dwight
fight back here to fly back here and you
know which countries do I help protect
in which countries I let go there's a
bit more to the tactical a - so the the
alien forces they come from the sea I
like you know Lovecraftian crustaceans
and they kind of evolved your tactics so
they're saying that you know if you are
you know primarily attack them from long
range of snipers and stuff they will
just evolve over the course of the game
to sort of block off that strategy to
you so you'll need to change it up quite
quite frequently from the sounds of
things and there was also a sort of that
style body targeting system that added
being added to the tactical layer and
also things like vehicles the stages
themselves are pretty good
quite a few sort of playthroughs that
you can see right now and the game is
actually in early access if you want to
sort of back it at a high tier like it's
kind of sort of like a slacker back a
thing if you like sort of sci-fi law
like they've added a lot of that in
there like little novellas that you can
just download and read
patently the full release is due around
June next year so yeah Phoenix point do
you let us know down in that comic books
what games you are looking forward to
next year especially on PC but we did
want to take this time to also thank you
for your comments on last week's video
where we talked about our favorite PC
games off the last year on YouTube we
got a comment from hearing Cho Han who
said return to the ER burden is a game
of the year this is the kind of game I
want to see more of getting made Lucas
Pope is a genius adding other games I'd
add our Delta rune demo Pathfinder
kingmaker bad stealth or subnautica Park
attacked and probably a few more that
I'm forgetting I just wanted to add this
one cuz firstly everyone was saying suck
Nautica is amazing this year yeah that
was like in January that's the very
beginning of this year and it's just
coming out of consoles now yeah yeah
it's been a PC game for a while yeah
okay like good to give these games of
shatta and especially Delta brewing
which I've heard is amazing that's Toby
Fox's new game the guy made undertale
apparently it's really great so if you
were into undertale there's another one
to sink your teeth into that you will
probably enjoy what's the problem my
dad's really loving bad still four so
cool also on YouTube paradox acres says
anyone played mutiny zero yet it looks
pretty good I have played this one it's
another tactical strategy game and the
man XCOM only this one has like a really
huge twist wherein it's all about
stealth
it's also has this really cool thing
where you actually explore the map in
real time so you movie cap is around the
map you squat around the map you split
them up and you set up ambushes it's not
so much about head-to-head combat
because you will almost always lose a
headache on that scenario so it's all
about moving around in real time
sneaking when patrols get near surveying
the map and like setting everyone up
instead of separate ambush spots and
then hitting go and then like taking
down as many individual targets silently
as you can if we get into a main
a sort of combat thing it's really
really good I've got this really great
post-apocalyptic post-apocalyptic
atmosphere and rest of all you get to
play as a bunch of animals yes that's
the kind of the best thing about it the
dock is called ducks
look at the pig is called Borman I think
yeah it's a really interesting take on
tactical strategy games and made me kind
of like to rewire my brain to like play
it well you know like I got really I got
owned in the first few battles because I
was like I'm going to go in guns blazing
really good tactical strategy games and
it's like no you got a plan you get an
ambush you gotta use stealth so yes meat
Nazira is sick
thank you for all your comments and
suggestions of great games over the last
year and do listener what you're looking
forward to and we'll see you again soon
goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you